jean michel est ce qu'on y est il se
passe pas avec ce courant d'un virus en
un mot on doit voir thor là maintenant
non monsieur je vais vous dire la vérité
parce que ce que vous avez montré tout à
l'heure ça m'a tétanisé le corps il part
sur france 2 qui a répondu à aucune
question oui quand vous avez un système
immunitaire fragilisé oui vous êtes en
menace pourquoi tout simplement parce
que le virus la seule façon que vous
avez vous en défendre aujourd'hui c'est
simplement votre propre immunité sympa
de traitement donc toute personne qui a
un système immunitaire fragile un
asthmatique un fumeur un diabétique et
cd rw oui il est potentiellement
aujourd'hui considérés comme plus
dangereux comme individuellement
individuellement la maladie olivier
perrin avec qui j'ai dominé s'est
récemment où il au ministre
olivier ferrand dit la même chose que
nous tous c'est à dire
qu'individuellement la maladie vous
n'êtes pas malade parce que vous avez le
corps en avion si vous avez un corps
navires us qui va pas forcément vous
tuez d'ailleurs pas citons coronavirus
îles samoa
il ya plein de porteurs sains
probablement il ya plein de gens qui ont
bravé du cornât virus sans le savoir
par contre on évite à l'heure actuelle
et les mesures qui sont prises sont
super à l'heure actuelle on évite la
pandémie ça veut dire on évite que toute
la france soit malade ont créé une
cohorte c'est super intelligent ce
qu'ils ont fait à l'heure actuelle ils
ont isolé des malades pour étudier et
fabriquer le vaccin à ce n est pas qu un
vrai un vaccin qui peut arriver vite ou
pas oui je pense qu'il va arriver
relativement vides dans les monts avis
dans les 8 10 semaines qui arrivent on
n'aurait jamais 8 10 semaines ça va être
long quand même parce que quand je vois
les consignes qu'on donne donc c'est à
dire vous êtes à l' isolement fait des
stocks alimentaires france après midi
elle a acheté 18 po d'harissa oui quand
vous dites que c'est juste le système
immunitaire qui peut nous guérir de ça
mais on est seul face à cette maladie et
les médicaments qui dit risque contre la
grippe peuvent nous aider quand même
est-ce qu'il ya des petits traitement de
fond habituel qui peuvent nous aider ou
c'est seulement nous mêmes c'est
seulement bon mais il n'y a pas de
médicaments qui guérissent la grippe a
il ya juste des médicaments qui enlève
les symptômes qui m'intéresse dans la
grée attention les prend ça pour nous
aider non mais vraiment si on les
parents salariés on se sert à rien on
donnera des médicaments pour éviter pour
faire descendre la fièvre pour se sentir
mieux mais s'aguerrir pas pour la
harissa vous avez tous rigolé vous avez
eu tort
il ya des aliments et c'est prouvé
scientifiquement je les dis chez un
autre de nos amis chez jean marc
morandini
il a des aliments qui renforcent
l'immunité scientifique de ça j'ai
notamment le piment je mange khodari ça
et c'est pour ça que ça ramène toi le
fond en avril je défonce et faire le con
malades et aux familles s'approche de
moi mais du sang larissa vont faire il
se voir direct et ça c'est un truc d'eau
et bien non rires non mais se jure que
c'est vrai mais c'est un truc de ouf
quoi c'est vrai oui il arrive ça c'est
bon mais où jean-marc demain sera celle
d'un mauvais roman en temps de pénurie
d'harissa
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on dit la vérité on avait acheté la
fabrique moi ça rigolait c'est un truc
de fou
alors il faut regarder tmp pour pas voir
le coronavirus et continuer à contribuer
oui double coup de gueule faire comité
des double coup de gueule que autre
chose au petit en ce moment et depuis
dix jours il ya autant d'avis que
médecin je pensais que la médecine
c'était une séance sur une chaîne c'est
une catastrophe en train de mourir et
sur l'autre a aucun danger rien si on
fait ça braille avis on peut tout sept
messages procès vous avez fait désolant
l'exploratrice et deuxième coup de
gueule je vois plein de médecins
maintenant qui arrivent et qui profitent
des plateaux pour dire au fait il ya 7
ans j'ai sorti un bouquin formidable
chez gallimard paris mains propres et
ils vont tout en bouquins sa pâleur et
tous les médecins se gavent ils
ressortent tous leurs bouquins et à la
médecine informant ils viennent tous
sortir un bouquin et raconter leur vie à
l'antenne alors il ya autant d'avis que
deux médecins assistants bras
complètement d'accord avec toi il ya des
gens qui racontent n'importe quoi mais
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent
exactement la même chose sur le sujet
c'est à dire vous n'avez pas plus de
craintes à avoir que pour d'autres
maladies individuellement les mesures
comprend à l'heure actuelle c'est pour
éviter une pandémie les gens à risque ce
sont des gens âgés qui sont fragilisés
tout ça on sait demain après il n'y a
pas besoin de faire des grandes théories
mais la psychose c'est la psychose alors
clément gars il paraît que ninja
warriors va être annulé aussi ninja
warrior il se pose la question de
retarder le tournage parce qu'il a vu
début avril
et il ya aussi un questionnement autour
du tour de france pour cet été se pose
déjà la question parce qu'on passe sur
une situation pandémique ça va durer
est-ce qu'ils s'embrassent sur la bouche
les coureurs n'ont pas les géants pour
le tout à leur dire dans l'air et c'est
un nom c'est une transmission de
personne à personne avec le contact s'il
n'y a pas de contact pour des rois tous
embrasser sur la bouche
pardon ma voix ne sont pas tous
embrasser sur la bouche non mais il y
avait des contacts rapprochés il y avait
des postillons il y avait du doigt par
exemple quand je parle avec les
coronavirus
[Rires]
je pourrais lui passé oui ce qu est ce
qu il est vrai qu'on a pu dire ça au
départ que quand les températures vont
remonter dans le virement c'est faux pas
du tout c'est faux c'est par ici
non non non il ya même des gens qui
avaient dit que c'était pour la raison
pour laquelle en afrique à l'heure
actuelle il ya très très peu de cas de
cornavin virus en afrique on n'a même
pas répertoriés par exemple qui concède
égal certains ont dit c'est la
température mais en chine il faisait
chaud pareil il y avait quand même du
conte indien sur rien pour la nature
docteur moi je sois du cul ya un risque
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez que je vous dise la vérité
jeudi tous des états unis si tu bosses
je double ton cash
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci madame
on a entendu dire que le coronavirus à
long terme pouvait devenir une maladie
saisonnière comme la grippe comme la
chine est ce que ceux ci ou ça c'est
possible on a deux problèmes avec le
coronavirus le plus gros problème que
personne n'évoque c'est la mutation n'a
rien et ça veut dire quand un virus peut
se transformer parce qu'ils s'habituent
à son hôte
ça veut dire que nous il va s'habituer à
notre défense il va il va commencer à
fabriquer ses défenses contre nos
défenses ça on n'a pas de garantie
aujourd'hui mais il est possible quand
la virus dans quelques années ils soient
identifiés comme n'importe quelle souche
grippale
et voilà il y en aura un vaccin contre
le canadien le premier il est comme ça
que tu or die il est quand même si c'est
ça qui couronna le 19 parce qu'il sait
pas le premier 19 c'est parce qu'il est
viré sur certains produits parce qu'il y
en a plusieurs
voilà sinon maintenant ce temps parce
qu'ils ont dit que les enfants étaient
transmettez mes n'était pas porteur ne
développait pas le virus est alors c'est
la grande interrogation qu'on a à
l'heure actuelle c'est pourquoi avant
dix ans on a des enfants qui sont des
porteurs sains et qu'ils développent pas
du tout la maladie et là ça vous
confirme la réponse que je vous donnais
tout à l'heure c'était les enfants d'un
système immunitaire beaucoup plus
développé que les adultes nous on perd
2,7 capacités immunitaires
donc apparemment il développe les
paniers se serre pas la main les enfants
et sont souvent dans des lieux saints ne
manquent pas dans des endroits d'arthur
[Musique]
oui très vite les docteurs vous êtes un
seuil qui était juste venu pour faire un
jeune élu pour faire un jeu mais c'est
tout une au fond vous êtes d'un naturel
gentille et vous avez un physique rond
et débonnaire tout le monde veut croire
non mais je vais bien sûr elle est venue
gentiment ici tu sais ce que vous êtes
en train de nous endormir
parce que là vous nous dites non mais
alors c'est pas messmer on nous dit que
tout va bien il n'y a pas de danger
c'est parce que les gens comme moi je
suis hyper inquiet quand je prends le
métro je fais attention je touche plus
rien escapade décalage entre ce que vous
direz la réalité que le déficit de
connaissance
il crée et l'anxiété ça veut dire que
maladie on a annoncé par exemple de
façon tragique il ya deux jours il ya un
mort il ya un mort ok il ya un mois on a
découvert qu'il est habile coronavirus
l'adama après qu'elle soit mort vous
n'avez pas avant donc il ya l'anxiété
d'halong mais par contre
individuellement je vous dis aujourd'hui
individuellement on n'a pas un
recensement d'une dangerosité immédiate
mais la pandémie
elle est vraiment la porte quand je vous
entends dire on est au stade de terme et
non on est à la porte du stade 3000 ha
[Rires]
on a battu pavé dans panic sud existent
en de bonnes mains
alors c'est quoi la pandémie la pandémie
c'est quand il ya une diffusion à
l'échelle nationale d'une maladie ça
veut dire que au lieu d'avoir un roster
par exemple 2000 cas on va avoir trois
millions de personnes qui vont être
infectées
ils sont plus moche et pas de mine c'est
seulement ça et là ça pose un problème
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure
économique c'est à dire tout va
s'arrêter quand les gens sont malades
ils s'arrêtent et donc qu'est ce qu'on
va faire on aura pas plein de choses
vous en avez vu vous des malades du foie
gras virus je pense que j'en ai vu sans
savoir qu'ils avaient le corps on a bien
eu ce week-end vous avez regardé sur
igor et grichka bogdanoff
non non non c'est vrai mais sans blague
mais dans les cabinets c'est vrai quoi
qu' il peut y en avoir qui aurions
évidemment mais je suis persuadé qu'il y
en a donc évidemment qu'il ya des gens
qui en ont besoin comme ça et qui sont
des porteurs sains mais qu'ils défendent
et et voilà qu'ils vont rien senti le
souffre
mais les gens viennent dans les cabinets
médicaux américains en interrogeant sur
la grippe etc
on sait pas ce qu'ils ont eux mêmes
comme les irradiés on peut attaquer à la
même pas ce que c'est il ya plein de
gens qui me disent cyril on a envie de
se marrer le soir ce que touche pas à
mon poste marche aussi bien en ce moment
c'est vrai que c'est tellement
angoissante sur les autres chaînes assis
à regarder bfm et ses nouvelles ses
frères même si t'as pas le corps humain
d'un virus sachant tumeurs de dépression
ça veut dire frères wright angoisse
tellement mon frère c'est toute la
journée après marc morandini sur ses new
skies un mois espère toute la journée
frère tandis de mourir il a réveillé ses
marquages donc c'est ça qui pose le
problème je n'en peux plus il ya des
régions comme la franche-comté loisil
c'est des gens qui ramène le coronavirus
ok mais la rue ni la raison ni tu ouvres
bfm ou tu ouvres n'importe quelle chaîne
d'info ça parle que de ça c'est au nez
c'est attendait les gens ils sont pris à
la gorge comme ça il en voit partout
mais sans et connaissez vous une bonne
médecine en france tout va bien on évite
la pandémie gouvernementale fonctionne
vous avez bien compris le message de
monsieur jean michel cohen qu'on aime
beaucoup qui est voilà qui est très
sérieux je vous le dis donc voilà on
gère la situation est gérée
il faut pas paniquer seulement il faut
prendre des précautions mine de rien
voilà c'est ça et il faut pas manger de
pain de mie